good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone is having an amazing blessed
and humbling tuesday i really do it is a
humbling tuesday because i felt that
yesterday was a particularly long day it
never ended it never [ __ ] ended
and
literally by the time it was time to go
to bed of course i couldn't fall asleep
i'm like the day wouldn't [ __ ] end
the day wouldn't end i actually think
the reason why i felt like the day was
so long is because like it actually was
a really long day we're heading into the
summer solstice yeah so the days are
like getting to be the longest they've
ever been like i was literally sitting
on my bed at eight o'clock and it was
still bright out and i'm like
can i go to sleep yeah no there was just
like weird [ __ ] going on in the universe
yesterday
and it was pissing me off it was just
such a long day i ate dinner so early
and then two hours later i was like
i need another dinner and then two hours
after my second dinner i needed a third
i have to say
there is a time in your life it's called
bsd and asd before second dinner and
after second dinner
when you come to a point in your adult
life you realize like you really like
aren't living until you have two dinners
everything changes after that like
a light dinner at like six and then like
a big heavy dinner at eight like there's
liter i'm actually maybe opposite like
big dinner at like 6 30 and then like a
second little you know leftovers at 8
30.
it's such a game changer and it's such a
fabulous like lifestyle change i really
recommend it
i'm usually okay with the one dinner i
just it was too early and it was too
small
and then all night today was too long
and the day was too damn long all night
i was just like and then zach ordered
food so i was like eating his dinner and
then it was just like i couldn't stop
eating that sounds fun you know things
happen like that sometimes
you're talking to the queen so yeah it
was just crazy and it was weird because
the bachelorette was on last night but
and i
i've had the time in the space you need
to watch it but i still chose not to
we are going to talk a little bit in the
tv recap about our journeys with the
season of the bachelorette but i just
want to say i'm so excited for today's
episode
one because we're just a couple fabulous
girls and fabulous outfits doing
fabulous things on our fabulous set
in our fabulous town somewhat fabulous
town um
but also we have i would say maybe the
most famous person who's ever been on
our show joining us at the end of this
episode we recorded an interview over
zoom
um podcast end video on youtube with
chelsea handler
who is now a fellow podcaster she's a
new podcast called dear chelsea and it
is like an advice
podcast so we decided to do deer
toasters with her so we are getting
extra lucky getting two deer toasters
this week today and tomorrow so if
you're listening as a podcast the
interview will be at the end of this
episode and if you're watching on
youtube we have our zoom interview up
with her
um in a separate video so that's just
very exciting very exciting so if you
wrote into your toaster some
of you are getting advice straight from
chelsea and she was
cut throat like she didn't have any time
honestly i wish i was more like that
like
and i really already feel like i am a
little bit like that but she was just
very cutthroat like made a decision and
stuck with it which is just not like
what i do yeah we are always
you know on the fence we're the fence
girlies yeah if you
like we stand for nothing you know like
we're just i think we stand for
everything
really i sit for most things but she
like every time like we give advice i'm
just like yeah well maybe and then
no actually i don't know like you can
either do this or that
the two choices that you do have right
no and she was just like cut them out
like she was just very cutthroat and she
was giving really good advice it was
really cool to talk to her so
that'll be at the end of the episode but
before that we have just tons to discuss
we have tons to discuss we have some
great news stories
and yeah other than that my dad
yesterday was like busy with
work stuff you know meetings meetings
meetings booked and busy
um even though i was so tired yesterday
i made it to the treadmill
which i was i was proud of myself for
doing that and other than that it was
just a beautiful day spent with brew
like what can i say
there's literally not much else that you
can ask for yeah
as a human being he's just been like
really extra special lately and i want
to do something special
for him what are you going to do i don't
know i always like want to take him
somewhere
show him the world yeah and so it's like
last time
when we took him away in march we went
on a little vacation little family
vacation with bruce did
the best time he had so much fun but it
was a little too cold now it's a little
too hot
um i just feel like it might be bruised
weekend
yeah broods day bruise day how's
doo doo doo doo doo's good is getting
groomed today um
it's just you know it's so exciting
being his mother and i'm so humbled
honored
and really blessed to be a part of his
life and his journey on
on this earth yeah no he he's a special
one
and we miss him today but we also not
only does he have spot services but
we have such a great guest today that we
really wore our tuesday
best for yeah it's really a wonderful
guest it's extremely wonderful so
you'll find out who it is tomorrow but
in the meantime enjoy today's
and let's hope that between now and an
hour from now this person doesn't cancel
for one reason or another because we
said that there was a person coming on
the show you know what i actually think
like the person is already in route to
the studio
so like there's literally no way that
this person could cancel yeah
so you never know because we are
constantly finding new ways to be
cancelled
right but we do look forward to speaking
to this person yes
yeah and that's that on that and you'll
find out tomorrow yeah
um so let's dive in because i have a lot
of thoughts on a lot of things that are
going on
okay so without further ado where are
you not here getting spa services
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and you know it's like coming back home
today's episode is brought to you by
scentbird have you ever had someone come
up to you and say you smell amazing what
perfume are you wearing
whatever scent you may be wearing you
have good taste and you know what you
like but your great taste is also
expensive and you end up with a shelf
full of half used bottles
or even wearing the same two perfumes
for years because going out to buy a new
one is a hassle
with senford we have found a way to have
great taste and mix up our fragrance
routine without breaking the bank
whether it's tom ford gucci or versace
sendbird.com keeps us smelling good
month after month
so i've tried many um perfumes from
sunburn and actually just got a whole
new
package of them but their rag and bone
fragrances are so good the malin goats
ones are so fresh and that's two
companies i never even would have tried
i'm a bulgari girlie
of course you are so senford is a
fragrant subscription service that gives
you the opportunity to shop from over
600 brands
it is a flexible subscription so you can
skip any month without penalties
scentbird lets you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month for just 16
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there are no
surprises they have perfumes and
colognes and a lot of unisex options as
well
you choose the perfume you want to try
and they'll send you a 30-day supply the
best part is that you get like a travel
friendly
um on-the-go size perfume because you
don't need a whole bottle if you don't
end up liking it or you end up liking it
you can just get it again in the next
month
um and they come in these fabulous
little compact travel cases that are
just great to have like period on the
carry top designer brands like prada
gucci and versace and if you're not
typical
what's that you're looking for you can
sort and find your new fragrance by
brand style occasion and more
and we have an exclusive offer for our
listeners you can get 30 off your first
month today
that's only 11 for your first fragrance
go to scentbird.com and use the code
toast for 30
off your first month again that's s c e
n t
bird dot com for you to try your first
perfumer cologne for just eleven dollars
sign on smell amazing oh it feels so
good and so good
okay first story some crazy news drake
bell the star of drake and josh has been
charged for crimes against a child
in ohio drake bell the former star of
the nickelodeon show jake and josh has
been charged on two counts of crimes
against a child in ohio
he is referred to by his first name
jared in the court documents
what yup he went to jared and was
charged with the attempted endangering
of children a fourth-degree felony and
disseminating
matter harmful to juveniles a
first-degree misdemeanor in 2017.
okay what are those charges is that like
child porn
disseminating harmful disseminating
matter harmful to juveniles could also
be like
drugs or alcohol oh yeah yeah right very
vague
charges i need a lawyer the charges are
vague
the story is so i mean it's not bizarre
if you've been following like kind of
the drake and josh of it all since drake
and josh you know
one of them is doing one thing and one
of them is doing the other thing and
they couldn't be more different yeah
um and drake has kind of been on this
troubled path for a while
um and this is just terrible this is
terrible like when you're cr
crimes against the kids yeah yeah when
you're when you're committing crimes
against children you know the camper
criminal like that's not cool
no not not at all whatsoever so um
hopefully
we get a little more clarity as to what
these crimes were yeah but
really really crazy i was actually
thinking recently about how like we
report on so many stories that we never
get follow-ups on yeah
what the [ __ ] happened to jake paul's
house i know why did the fbi rate it
i don't know whatever happened to josh
duggar because we never heard about well
josh duggar's
this is new like it's ongoing what what
happened next it's been like two months
i think it's been like two weeks no
cause no because taylor's trucker was
here oh
i'm sure like you could find out but i'm
not no offense i'm not gonna
no i'm just i'm not gonna keep y'all
abreast on the duggars i saw the
craziest headline about the duggars
today
so did i jill and the other [ __ ] and
what and the dog
and the breast milk yes yes what
according to this headline allegedly
she's defending her decision she's
defending her decision to give
unused breast milk to her dog and i just
feel like honestly what goes on in
people's homes is truly none of my
business and i do
wish we kept it that way like i don't
need to know this is like the
beauty and it's a blessing and a curse
with the internet you know you get to
know about more people and learn about
their lives but some people be out here
on the internet just like sharing way
too much [ __ ] information
and i'm not interested in jill duggar
breastfeeding her dog cause now i have
like just a mental image of her
you know rottweiler hanging off her neck
but like i just didn't need that today
no no i don't think that the rocks
breastfeeding but that is the image that
went in my mind because i'm [ __ ] up
oh yeah you definitely are um also a
little
more details about the case with uh
drake bell is that um
the public information officer told cbs
news that he led that um
a female juvenile victim filed a report
with her local police department in
october 2018
she claims that the election incident
with bell occurred at a nightclub in
cleveland in
ohio in 2017. still not really
sharing what it is it is but why did it
take so long
but it also was crimes against a child
so maybe that stuff is sealed
yes i just
i don't support drake bell so like
yeah no like you could either be a drake
or you could be a josh and i'm choosing
to be a joshua's like a child and a nice
marriage and he has a new show on
disneyland
influencers ben has been on his podcast
check it out so yeah i'm much more of a
in this world don't be a drake be a josh
hundred percent
yeah and that's the lesson of the day
kids are you ready for our next story
it's a little fashion news from a couple
of fashion influencers it's a couple
it's a little fashion news from a couple
of maxinistas
no i never said i was a maxinista oh
that's a title
you i am definitely maxine jackie
whether you want to admit it or not
we've all got a little max and he's
staying on us that's
true that's yeah you're thrifty yeah oh
yeah not all the time but you can be
quite thrifty i can be i really can be
you saw that shirt i was wearing
yesterday i've had that shirt for
six years thrift day i wore it on say
yes to the dress claudia's episode
yes you did real ones will remember real
ones will remember
okay next story fashion news kanye
west's first gap yeezy collab
has dropped the first item and only item
is a 200
blue jacket with no zipper he wore it a
few weeks ago and now
gap posted um a video of it on their
instagram page and they took out a huge
ad in the paper this morning
one page jacket the other page qr code
to buy the jacket i like the jacket i
just want to say
um two things really quickly one
speaking of stories we like never get a
follow-up on like we talked about the
kanye easy gap collection like literally
two years ago and like now it's here
okay we finally got to follow up
and two um totally unrelated remember
how we were saying how
chris jenner was wearing that 8-1-8 vest
yeah i bought it
oh my gosh they made merch i saw i
bought it i can't believe you bought it
it was a little expensive i bought it
and i'll probably like never wear it but
it's a collector's item
interesting yeah okay the other merch
was truly hanging out i was hoping they
would sell those like
bucket hats they did not the party that
were giveaways because i looked at the
merch site yeah it was like very basic
but the
i saw the school yeah okay cool i'm
happy for you let's go skiing
is that what it is
it's like a vest you wear a turtleneck
underneath i don't know a vest is a hard
item
yeah so i'll just wear it like if we
ever go skiing again okay
look to the lodge for some cocoa but no
for somebody one eight and i'll be
wearing this gap yeezy jacket
it's cool yeah i mean i like it i mean
it's like on the one hand looks like a
jacket on the other hand it is
innovative like and it's made out of
recycled nylon and also like that's not
a really
the sort of puffer we've ever seen yes
it's a it's a fresh
take on the down puffer and kanye's
always fresh always i mean honestly i
hadn't even seen this
i do find myself like staying less and
less abreast with kanye like after the
kim of it all i can't lie
i'm keeping i'm taking both sides in the
divorce i'm supporting
both artists designers
um yeah but like gun to my head i'm with
kim you know
i know i understand but i'm i'm with
both of them okay
i think we all support kimmy also chloe
posted this morning it's kanye's
birthday today
yes and so she posted the cutest picture
ever of her
tristan kim and kanye saying happy
birthday to my forever brother
yay and it just warmed my heart she also
posted some pictures yesterday of the
kids
the kids the campers were looking so
[ __ ] bad warmed my heart
matching purple outfits dream was in
there you know just like everyone else
dream true and chicago and then also
natalie who's a little younger than the
others but still wore purple
but still wore purple and the other the
three kardashian kids who were matching
were just like
so cute it just touched me there's also
i thought
what you were gonna say is like there's
so much going on with chloe like
she is like just starting drama left
right and center she did like an
instagram story yesterday
just like kind of like shaming people
who use one-use plastic water bottles
and like everyone on the planet was like
girl like are you serious like okay you
use uh hydro flask good for you but like
you literally throw parties like
every single day with like a thousand
balloons that are not recyclable like
just the list of what chloe does not to
help the environment is probably longer
than the list of things she does do to
help the environment
so it was just like a little
hypocritical and then there was like
another photo of her like looking like
flowy kardashian
and then people were like going in
making fun of her for her migraine
commercial like she's just not was not
having a good social media day yesterday
oh why were they those commercials have
been out for a while no i know
and like trues in them like they're cute
popcorn on the couch yeah i don't know
what the problem with the
migraine commercial is because millions
of americans suffer from migraines i'm
literally in the process
did i not say 20 minutes ago i'm getting
a migraine right now like
millions of americans so chloe get that
back that doesn't bother me the
hypocrisy of like the whole single
plastic water thing was like a little
stupid no and she was called out and i'm
sure when she saw it that way she was
like oh yeah
yeah sorry sorry and like flying private
jets like
on one hour flights like that's just
also not great for the environment like
it was just a little bit
i totally agree so yeah so she was just
not having a good day on social media
yesterday and she was like doing her
best to like
combat it but she just shouldn't have
started with the internet because like
the internet has really not been happy
with khloe kardashian for like the last
two years well i just want to say
someone who follows chloe but i'm not i
don't keep up with all the drama like
you do
i i saw the water bottle thing i didn't
see the migraine thing and i didn't see
the flowy kardashians it was all on
twitter and i know you stay away from
twitter i do stay away from twitter but
i did see
the picture of the cutest campers and
then the double date she posted this
morning that was clearly from kim's
birthday
and i just it really brightened my day
oh you i don't know if we ever also
spoke about this we've like a lot of
kardashian catching up to do this is the
kardashian ketchup
we're literally keeping up with the
kardashians um a lot of people were
convinced that kim
we found out on the show that she
actually ended up having that
she everyone thought that she got it
from her trip she said that she got it
um
i'm saying because he got it from
someone at school but do you think she
got it on the trip no not at all i
thought the timeline of
everything was so weird because she had
like no time in between
her birthday and like doing the thing
for chris's birthday and then also like
then she got covered but then it's like
the holidays and
so i i'm not sure when exactly she got
cove but i don't think it was from the
trip because other people would have had
it too
yeah and they could have easily not
shared that that's what i was going to
say like if she did
end up getting tr uh covered from a trip
that she got so much backlash for
she never would have shared it because
it's like everyone who gave her you know
[ __ ] for going on a trip
would have been right and i don't think
she would have given people that
satisfaction it never crossed my mind
yeah no but the internet was like
convinced that like she got it on the
trip
the internet can be wrong you guys
that's an important lesson
more often than not the internet is
wrong
and more morally corrupt internet yeah
no the
internet like doesn't know [ __ ] about
[ __ ] sometimes sometimes yeah yeah
sometimes they're onto something you
know 100 sometimes like a little gut
instinct from some random tweet
hilaria baldwin literally the craziest
thing to me is that
the global scandal that was hillary
baldwin
um started from a random twitter user
like just a thread of all the times
hilaria baldwin pretended to you know
have a spanish background
yeah and that's literally what started
this global news story and that is like
a
a moment where like the internet is like
saying working same with all the ellen
stuff
yeah it was like a tweet like share your
worst experience with ellen and then
yeah everyone like came out of the woods
and i'll donate a dollar for every
person who shares like a food pantry
yeah yeah there's like a lot of also
more things going on with ellen she's
like gearing up for like this enormous
final season all the guests are coming
out yeah
and didn't she also do an interview
recently where she like spoke about her
cancellation how it was like this
orchestrated like smear campaign against
her
maybe i had a dream about that i i
literally that doesn't sound familiar
and also like
i don't think that it started like
grassroots right
no i actually think i actually had a
dream about it oh interesting your
dreams are
so like trending and and up to date
100 could confuse your real life do you
know who i dreamt about last night
speaking of trendy and up-to-date like
things we've been talking about addison
ray
logan paul what was he doing we were all
going out together and i was on the
impulsive show
that's so cool i think i might have been
like watching on tick tock and like some
clips from his podcast like came up
and i sent you that video of jake paul
that like yes that meme yeah so like i
just think the paws were on my mind oh
by the way i think i'm also like in love
with logan
also yesterday when i said that logan
and jake should fight each other and i
thought it was a new idea like
apparently everybody's been saying that
so why don't they do it
they're really saving it like yeah i
know i think they also want to
like use the momentum they both have to
establish themselves as real boxers and
they're like building up
their bodies for the fight against the
two of them yeah also
i when does it come out how many people
bought that pay-per-view floyd
mayweather logan paul i haven't seen it
i don't know
i'm so curious so curious because i want
to know how much logan made he only got
10 of the bag but he also
i followed him on instagram this morning
i never followed him before and his
shorts had like a million sponsors atari
was a sponsor
his own clothing company was a sponsor
fashion nova it was like very like
influencery
so i'm curious how much just that
sponsorship yeah he made more obviously
than just like the pay-per-view
bag for sure and so did floyd because he
had an only fan's hat he had fashion
nova on his shorts he had the money team
sponsored
everywhere so like it was just a it was
synergy at its finest it was a vertical
integration it was a very
capitalist event truly okay well the
easy jacket is here go check it out
i want to get one but i like feel like i
don't know how to go and get it well
yeah is it like a
like is it going to sell out but it's
the gap so is it everywhere like i don't
know how these things work
i don't know what the supply and con
chain of command is
it's pre-order oh so i should get one
i'll get here right in time for
um for winter i'll be so cool yeah it's
a very cool
concept yeah very very cool okay
next up a little casting news that is
just so exciting because one
just found out we are getting an nbc
version of annie live
and two taraji p henson will be playing
miss hannigan
in some apt casting news in some
captioning news that is literally like
one of the best
cast on point yeah the oscar-nominated
actress will play ms hannigan the
infamous head of the orphanage where
annie lives before she is adopted
by daddy warbucks um daddy warbucks
should be jeff bezos
oh my god yeah no bringing back victor
garber he's so excellent
she is following in the footsteps of
actresses such as kathy bates
cameron diaz jane lynch nell carter
jane lynch she must have done broadway
like a lot yeah
because that she wasn't in the movie no
cameron diaz was in the movie and cathy
bates
kathie lee gifford sally strothers
joanne worley and
faith prince to name a few i mean i
thought cameron diaz also did a really
good job
unbelievable i think like it's it's
really a great role
and it takes a great woman to do it and
i think taraji p henson is going to be
excellent i'm so excited to see i first
of all annie's just one of those shows
that they could like do a million times
it can't really get spoiled like it
can't get outdone
it's we've had so many annie's like yeah
we just had the revenge in a wallace
such a good annie
such a good answer you guys if you
haven't watched the newest annie it's so
good
the music is so good it's done by sia
it's jackie's like favorite
underrated like favorite movie so it's
so so good check it out and it's like
modern and you know they have technology
and cell phones and like mr stacks he's
like um
he's like a tech guy and he's also like
running for mayor it's just like really
really well done
yeah the stories are so layered but i
think this one will be probably like the
original broadway play
live because it's going to be a chaotic
live performance
i've missed the live performance yeah
you know what if
if getting back to real life means we
have more mvc live productions and
all of their chaotic glory i'm here for
it me too because you want to know why
once again it's just like fun to be a
part of something like we're all
watching the same thing and like
cringing at it and it's just
it's a collective cringiness and i love
that for one
but on the off chance that they really
get it right it could be magic greece
does taraji b henson sing
i'm i don't know well she was in empire
and that's a musical show yeah i never
watched it but
yeah yeah the network is launching a
nationwide search for a young star to
play annie
oh like a like a tit tiller often like a
nikki blonsky
yeah oh i first of all i love that idea
but if we are
casting like from hollywood who are you
having play annie
who's like the next honestly it should
be jacob trebley how are you great
like hey like i don't know jacob charmer
is growing up though
i know maybe he could be one of the
orphans yeah well
i think it was just girls only oh was it
when you think back on it molly and
piper yeah
okay but so who we have got annie to
cast we've got taraji
who are daddy warbucks yeah and he wore
bucks against jeffy so it's like
they look alike they're both bald i
think it should be elon musk he
obviously proves that he can act
yeah sure he can sing that's true i
think that would be
so good i think so too and then also you
need um daddy warbucks's
secretary who he like falls in love with
at the end also
the dog theo theo or i think bruno is
going to go out for the role he's been
feeling really confident and he thinks
that
he he thinks that he can do it and i i
am
fully supportive it's just like a little
awkward because you know like theo's
already you know called his agent about
it
yeah but you know what like theo's gonna
have to work for it because brew is
coming
you're literally bruno is santana and
theo is lea michelle in glee when like
she goes out for
uh fanny bryce yeah and
she gets the understudy yeah yeah bruce
can be theo is under setting
sure and then theo mysteriously gets ill
and then bruno starts [ __ ] blood
anyways it's gonna be really good
hopefully but i think this bodes well
and it's a great selection of like what
the first kind of entree back into live
theater which can be so scary it's a
great selection
yes so and it's a great casting taraji p
henson so
for now i'm hopeful and it's a hard
knock life
knock knife four actually it's a great
soundtrack it's a great time
out it's camper-friendly it's
camper-oriented
i think they should get some of the
campers in there and i think counselor
should play ms hannigan in
next time oh my god that kid who went
viral i forget he won like a not maybe
not an oscar but like a sag award
and he's crying in that video yeah we
need to get him in like he's just like
he's the camper of the moment right now
what's his name i don't want to say it's
alan kim i'm not sure but
unfortunately like male campers so
there's no roles for them find one
find one yeah he needs to be in annie
live
even though he's like kind of too good
for like local theater you know i don't
know it's a good
like it's a good if you love the craft
it must be a good
exercise what is your favorite most
recently
like done production of a live grease
yeah what about um [ __ ] stellar
hairspray
hairspray they didn't time it well
everyone was out of breath yeah and rent
was
um a tragedy
yeah like it was a trap breaking legs
getting sick
it was terrible they had to did they
use the dress rehearsal as like the live
thing
that was so tragic oh my god
i feel so bad for everyone involved 100
damn okay ready for our next story only
if it's a story that's brought to you by
bruce
it is oh it is these two in this story
are gonna need a bruise if they keep
going the way they're going
well wake up and get yourself a bruce
the best electric toothbrush on the
market it is the most affordable a lot
of electric toothbrushes
can charge over 200 which is insane
bruce is
literally the most stunning it works so
well and it's the most affordable it
comes with six unique modes that you can
customize your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks so if
you're going on a trip you don't need to
charge it
um but also the magnetic charging stand
is like very elegant clutter free
it looks great on your countertop very
elon musk approved and it also comes
with a compact travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head
they will ship you a new replacement
head every six months so you're never
stuck using one that's old or
has bacteria on it you got to keep
changing it but you don't need to
remember because bruce will remind
you with their subscription service and
they have brand new designs we just got
both colors jackie got the mauve i got
the green it's
they're so stunning but they're seasonal
so they only last a certain amount of
time
on the electric the electric toothbrush
from bruce has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design
and it comes in trend driven seasonal
colors that look great on your bathroom
counter
get 15 off your brush toothbrush kit and
refill plan
when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code toast.brush.com
love it okay kristen cavallari says
she's charmed while hanging out with
southern charms austin kroll in
charleston
these two are really sounding like if it
walks like a duck and talks like a duck
their sound they look like an item
yeah but also like didn't we talk about
this a year ago and it was like they
weren't in december but like
i think in december they weren't at
night i mean she was dating someone else
yeah that like comedian yeah jeff died
but i think
now they are an item they were spotted
together again in charleston over the
weekend after spending time with one
another in
december a trip that sparked romance
rumors that they denied the two were
once again reunited hanging out at a
south carolina eatery leon's oyster shop
the pictures are so cute they appear to
be smiling in a photo um
hanging out with craig and another
friend and
i think they're dating i mean i support
it i think it's a really cute like
really like stunning couple um
i just don't know like i don't know what
to believe i got so excited about this
last time and then it turned out to be
nothing of the source no when i first
heard it i was like there's no way
they're dating like she's just hanging
out with them like they're not dating
but now i think they are
i hope so like i do support it i think
it's a cute couple but like when will we
know for sure
i don't know also did you hear about all
this like divorce drama like jay cutler
wants half of uncommon james
in the divorce no yeah like he's going
after her business
which is crazy because like let her have
her thing like you made 150 million
dollars in one year playing football
like yeah
leave uncommon alone no i haven't seen
that yeah check it out it's getting
messy so hopefully she's
just so unfortunate finding solace in
the arms of a young stud from southern
charm like austin kroll
and i think that she is i hope so yeah
i'm sure they like started out as
friends they didn't want to
date like i'm sure she was like not
looking at him in that way but then you
know
love that you can't stop the forces and
there's also rumors that
craig is dating paige from summer house
but those rumors are not true
okay i just like i'm still living in the
world where like i would like for them
to be true so just don't bring me down
100
but i'm pretty sure i don't know i don't
remember where i heard but it's not true
i just feel like and i just feel like
this one's true i feel like it could be
you know though i do feel like craig
austin kristen page iconic quad an
iconic quadrant
like iconic couples doing iconic things
being iconic and i fully support it
even though no one's asking yeah no 100
are you ready
for our fifth and final story it's the
final story
okay it's a little fashion news and i
would say this is the pinnacle of
fashion this
always happens whenever you say fashion
news you literally say
it's little fascist news like i always
think that's what you're going to say
because you put so much emphasis on
fashion i'm like oh well what are the
fascists up to today
oh my god i didn't know that yeah no
it's a little not the first time
again like the way you just said it the
words are similar no i know but like
you're just putting a lot of emphasis on
the sh it's a little fashion news
perfect fashion that's how i'll say it
stiletto crocs are here to erase all of
your pandemic
comforts check out these check out these
bad boys
[ __ ] stunning you guys
high fashion never rest never the
comfort of the kobe 19 pandemic has
taken a dangerous turn
balenciaga has unveiled its latest
collaboration with crocs in the form of
a narrow heel
placed precariously on the soul of its
trademark rubber clog
the monstrosity was unveiled at the
fashion houses spring 2022
balenciaga clones collection showing and
immediately drew the ire
of pandemic worn social media someone
wrote
god has abandoned us but is the heel
also rubber i don't know how that works
it looks like you'd be wobbling around
it looks like it's of a similar elk
that is so stunning you guys it's
so horrific we'll post on our instagram
but you know crocs really did
they had their moment this year and like
rocks i'm telling you like
they kind of leaned into their marketing
was so genius they leaned into like the
jokiness of crocs being the crocs are
ugly like
for years there have been memes and they
just kind of went along with it and now
crocs have weirdly entered
firmly into the zeitgeist no and now
they're entering high fashion i just
want to say like i
i fully support crocs i actually i love
rocks in general i love
the comfort and everything i do believe
we've taken it
way too far with a balenciaga collab
like
it's just wrong no i know and it's like
for so long like i think i've really
agreed with a lot of
the decisions the marketing team over at
crocs has done like the luke homes
collection was
literally put them on the map justin
bieber collection was great they just
announced a diplo collection they're
doing great collabs this one
missed the mark yeah but like watch us
in a year like wearing crocs stiletto
to my prom yeah yeah no like oh
someone's cool is wearing them look at
us
yeah i'll try it i mean i'll try
anything once
i don't know it except like acid i don't
really feel like i'll have fun doing it
i just don't think
i i think they're counterintuitive
though a high heel is supposed to
enhance a woman's leg and the croc does
the opposite so if you're not if your
leg's not going to be enhanced
why are you wearing a high heel that is
a stunning fashion analysis like
no more needs to be like that's just
really when you get down to it
yeah it's science at this point a
hundred percent um let's do a little tv
recap because
even though i promised i wasn't gonna
watch about tourette i did watch about
29 minutes of it which was more than
enough for me to know that
i'm not going to continue to watch it
also siesta key was on last night we
even recap that in a while well i caught
up on cst last night i just like wasn't
ready to read i was just in a weird spot
and i was like i just want to watch some
like good reality tv i've been meaning
to catch up on fiesta key
so i watched the first two episodes of
the season i have so many thoughts okay
good because our tv recap is brought to
you by frame bridge you've heard us talk
about frame bridge before so you know
they make it super easy and affordable
to custom frame your favorite things
from print and posters to the photos on
your phone father's day is around the
corner and dad doesn't want another pair
of socks
the perfect gift is already on your
phone just upload your photo and order
by tuesday june 15th
for guaranteed free delivery and time
for father's day here's how it works
go to framebridge.com and upload your
photo preview your item online in any
frame style choose your favorite or get
free recommendations from their talented
designers
the expert team at frame bridge will
custom frame your item and deliver your
finished piece
straight to you or they can deliver to
dad in time for father's day
when you place your order again by
tuesday june 15th instead of the
hundreds you'd pay at a traditional
framing store their price start at 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners will get 15
off their first order at framebridge.com
when they use the code toast
so for any occasion i feel like frame
bridge especially if you're decorating
your own home
is an amazing service to use but with
father's day like
dads are so sentimental and i feel like
really just getting like a stunning
photo of you eyes
framed make it super nice frame bridge
takes care of all the hard part and it's
really affordable so you just look like
the best kid
when you really put in minimal effort
and that's just ideal order a custom
gift for any dad in your life go to
framebridge.com and use promo code toast
you'll save an additional 15 off your
first order just go to framebridge.com
promo code toast again that's
framebridge.com promo code toast for 15
off your first order love framework do
you know who needed frame bridge
on siesta key that [ __ ] picture that
that that artist made of juliet you guys
i was in shock i've no i didn't know
what to expect it was like a weird thing
that sam
had this picture commissioned by like
this girl right by like this girl that
he hooked up with like this thotty
artist yeah the thought is the artist
and but they also are bringing her onto
the show so it's like a good way to
bring her onto the show but like to have
like
this girl who clearly wants your mans
like paint
a photo of you like how scary is that
going to turn out because she's not
going to make you look stunning
yeah and not only did she make juliet
look busted upon closer inspection
she painted julia's face to look like
her own and it was just
shocking hysterical i hope they put that
picture in the fire
isn't it crazy just like how far so many
of the cast mates like
have come like when you watch brandon's
storyline like it is
shocking well i don't watch brandon's
storyline that's the only storyline i
have to fast forward and what's so crazy
is his storyline
is actually the most interesting yeah um
plot
and you know it's so real but i can't
i can't watch him i'm sorry like it's
too slow and mind-numbing and the
conversations aren't too painful
no the girl it's not even like his
girlfriend like it's just like this girl
who
he had a baby with the way that she
stares at him
like she wants to eat him she's so
obsessed and in love with him like i
almost want them to just like be a
family
no totally i watched the first scene of
the first episode enough to know that i
wasn't going to continue on with brandon
scenes but it was
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen like the fact that he got himself
like
in this position i know um and now he
has to deal with the consequences
of his really bad choices i mean when
that girl told him
that she was pregnant and he blocked her
on social media until she gave birth
like
that's atrocious behavior atrocious
behavior and so now we
and my only issue with siesta key is
there's so much stuff that happens
between this group of friends like
every day something new and the show
doesn't capture it we only get the
conversations talking about what just
happened and
the conversations are so painful
sometimes so i'd like they honestly need
to put these people in a house together
so we see
every single thing that happens i just
think a lot of it has to do with covet
like
yeah yeah no but that's why i mean sam
jayla got an island
on i i mean this probably happened a few
weeks ago if you watch live but for me
the next episode i'm watching they're
going to an island so i think they're
going to solve that issue that i'm
having
um but it's crazy how much drama unfolds
and how the
the um dynamics are constantly changing
no and it's like for me like i can't
relate to it because like i've had the
same friends for
25 years and i've made no new friends
since then like the way like julian and
kelsey best friends forever like can't
be separated now they can't stand each
other like
to be so wishy-washy with your friends
is like crazy yeah and
it was giving me like moves making me a
little sad so it's like kelsey and julia
were such good friends i wish they could
be good friends again but like
can juliette ever trust kelsey like
imagine these are your closest friends
and you can't even trust them and you go
to her
boyfriend and say she's using it for her
money like it's horrible horrible
so it's just like such crazy stuff
happens but they brought on some new
cast members who i like i mean brandon's
ex um i think is so great and i hope she
stays on the show
madison it's so crazy like the genesis
that i've had with these people because
yes
in the first season i was like
everybody's obsessed with this girl
madison like
what and now and now i'm like madison is
the queen of the show like she's just on
another level
she's so mature and maybe that's because
she's dating an older man yeah but she
really is like on another like
intellectual level
she really really is and i mean julia's
still the queen of the show and i love
her so much and i and
it really bothers me that kelsey's like
i don't think you're happy in your
relationship and it's like you don't
even care about me so why do you care
from happy or not and like how do you
know
like we i don't even talk to you because
i think i like i don't know that much
but i think julia is happy and really
like i see her instagram like she seems
really happy she's on private jets she's
doing just
like how bad could it be and also like
even their conversations i saw someone
like commented like sam's kind of
awkward on the show which is by the way
like
that's what you want out of your
boyfriend not to be a natural robbie
hayes
right right right right and i just feel
like
he i feel like he really loves juliet
for juliet i by the way i agree i think
he's like so cute he's definitely weird
like on the show but like
you're right what do you want a
professional actor like that's always
shady and those are the people who's
just gonna [ __ ] you over and use you for
your platform or whatever
100 robbie hayes yeah so like okay so
she went from having someone who was
like too good on the show now people
like he's weird
i think it's good it's a good sign i
think it's a good sign too so anyways it
was been a really like a pleasure
to watch and the visuals just keep
getting more stunning
but some of it is so so funny
and the art oh my god i was i was in
shock
i watched the first 30 minutes of the
bachelorette because i was like
it was eight o'clock and i'm like i'm
literally doing nothing like okay
so i watched it and i was of course
watching it at 50
maybe even 25 percent um
and it took 30 minutes for us to
actually meet a guy and right when
the first guy took stepped out a limo i
just turned it off because here's what i
analyzed from my
29 minutes on the show first um
they're filming it at a hyatt in new
mexico and it's just giving me like
how low budget tasha and claire's was
like it's giving me the same budget
energy it's not giving me my colon
energy
i feel like the bachelor has a much
higher production budget
just based on what i've seen like that
tasha season when they got engaged in
that rock like it was pathetic like it
was
and now it's like we're getting the same
thing it's like it's a big ass
property that seemingly looks nice but
it's like a [ __ ] model home inside
like
and i just know all the dates are going
to be on this hyatt property and i'm
just not in the mood to have
i had to survive through quarantine i
don't need to watch these other people
do it
this group of guys was even i only saw
like the first like 10. they were just
like especially illusory and giving me
like super desperation vibes
um there was one guy who was a
firefighter who macholai like was really
cute and according to
the snatchers instagram greg is yeah
i didn't really feel like he was all
that special i don't know why everyone
was like simping over him
um and then there was a guy who was a
motivational speaker
which i just feel like is a really
thirsty job it reminds me of you know
caitlyn jenner like i just feel like
no but like that would also mean that
the person is like an olymp
a decorated olympian no but like i feel
like this is going to be like maybe like
offensive i just feel like it's a big
job
so i feel like you go on the bachelor to
get followers for your motivational
speaking company unless you are a
decorated olympian
right it's a fake job yeah like what no
offense like who are you why should you
motivate me
a hundred percent what have you
accomplished no you know who's a
motivational speaker
robbie hayes yeah it's the same vibe
like you know what i'm saying
yeah so i just feel like that job is
it's a red flag it's people who post on
instagram like rise and grind
and then yes and then you motivated
someone yeah so like i feel like there
are certain jobs when you come on the
bachelor like of course like
when mckenna went on and she was a
fashion blogger red flag like that just
is a red flag
motivational speaker like gave me major
red flag vibes and then just like all
these guys were so unremarkable
and to me like i couldn't differentiate
who was who and
katie was just giving me nothing like
the whole you know they have to latch on
to something so kate you know what's her
thing
sex positive because she brought a dildo
which
great i think being sex positive is
awesome unfortunately it's not a
personality trait and like
you're gonna have to talk about other
stuff so like i was just and all the
like the few things that i saw like the
guys were just like trying to like
mimic you know it's kind of how colton
was a virgin and like that was all the
jokes and it got really annoying really
[ __ ] fast
this is the same thing so i just i don't
like
die for katie enough to make me stay i
did want to see the dynamic without
chris harrison
and with tasha and caitlyn and here's
what i will say
there is a palpable feeling of something
missing
something guiding the show katelyn and
tasha are great they're funny
they bring like a sense of happiness and
positivity and security to katie but
that's not enough in my opinion i don't
feel like
their job was to steer the show as much
as chris used to
um and the show was missing that element
of like who's in charge here like
there's no direction it's kind of just
like chaos in new mexico
yeah so i um i say i won't watch but
maybe i will
um but for now i'm all set got it well
thank you for
your recap if you want more head over to
the snatcher new episode is up now i
can't wait to listen and hear what she
has to say
and the episode is not over because if
you're listening as a podcast you're
about to hear our interview
and dear toaster segment with the one
and only chelsea handler
comedian icon podcaster and if you're
watching on youtube and you want to
catch the video of us in chelsea it's on
our channel now
check that out and thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
we'll see you tomorrow for
hump day yes goodbye
you